one of the most important periods in
Charles's life is the time he spent in a
private school tell us a little bit more
about that this time at boarding school
was anything but Posh oh my gosh um you
could even say that I think in today's
by today's standards uh quite
controversial and downright
um barbaric barbarians right right well
Charles attended a Scottish boarding
school called gordonston and he
described the experience as pure hell
torture I hated every minute of it and
what he went through was really quite
alarming I mean as as a boy and a young
man he was uh routinely beaten by older
students he was uh uh hung up in a naked
in the shower and and left sprayed with
cold water and left there he was uh um
pummeled and wrestled to the ground and
uh he wrote These he wrote These
pleading letters to his parents to
please take him out of the school he
went to them and sobbed saying he
couldn't take it anymore and yet they
turned their back on him and one of his
schoolmates said it was a miracle that
he emerged uh with his sanity intact
from that experience something yeah it
really oh my gosh he even went through
moments of depression yeah Suicidal
Thoughts because of this oh yeah yeah
certainly to by today's standards uh it
would be akin to hazing or uh you know
child abuse frankly yeah and yet his
parents turned a blind eye uh to it and
I think that caused a tremendous
resentment you know the Queen's cousin
Margaret Rhodes told me the relationship
between uh Charles and his parents was
never cozy because the family is not set
up to be cozy she said it's the firm
Charles's time at boarding school
obviously traumatic compounded with the
fact that he was attempted shy
oftentimes found that he didn't belong
in a setting right
with all those factors coming into play
what is King Charles's temperament these
days well it's interesting
um Charles uh was shaped by all these
experiences as a result he's always seen
himself as a what the British call a
whinger uh you know as a victim a Winger
is a Winer a complainer yeah but he
always cast himself as the victim and
Camilla's role has always been to kind
of try and Tamp that down and by the way
I have to say that the biggest
misconception about Charles at this
moment is that he will be a placeholder
King that he's just you know keeping the
throne warm for William not at all he's
going to be an activist King he's been
waiting for 70 years to take this job
and it's longer than any previous
Monarch where Edward VII only had to
wait 59 years to succeed Queen Victoria
so he's going to do some bold moves I
think and to change and what he calls
slim down the monarchy and part of that
is going to be to kick some
in some cases beloved royals off the
payroll or just demote them some of the
staff have been quoted as saying in your
book he shouts insults to staff he's
Moody he's mean he can't admit himself
that he is ever at fault right well
because they can't because the king and
by the way it's really hard to sustain
that because he's been known as Prince
Charles forever right yeah but uh no he
is he's very moody he's very
temperamental he has a volcanic temper
in fact uh one of his uh ballets
described a scene where he lost a
cufflink down the sink Charles did and
got so angry that he actually tore the
sink Off the Wall he did this twice by
the way in two different places uh he
also grabbed one servant around the neck
and tried to strangle him in a fit of
rage he hurled a very heavy boot Jack
which is put on Boost it's made out of
iron and wood he threw this at Diana's
head and narrowly missed her so he's
very capable of flying into rages and
can be a little bit of a hot head a
little bit of that with the signature of
some documents recently absolutely and
the pen incidents right I think 10 Gates
I mean here we are he's just become king
he's in Scotland uh he really should be
on his best behave Behavior the world is
watching his every move by the way there
are other little quirks too about his
temper but that I think reveal the
degree to which he's going to be one of
the most eccentric uh Sovereign Great
Britain has ever had he still travels
with a childhood teddy bear please tell
us more about Teddy yes Teddy is it you
know he's had it since he was a very
spoiled child the only person who's been
allowed to mend King Charles's teddy
bear uh is his childhood Nanny Mabel
Anderson whom he's very close to but he
also travels with a custom-made toilet
seat that he's and he's denied this but
again people who work in the palace
people who've worked for him say that he
indeed does this uh he when he goes to
dinner parties at other people's homes
he often brings his own Chef so they can
prepare a meal for him that he will eat
separately at the table and it doesn't
matter to him how the chef for the event
or no no the dinner party no no he wants
what he wants when he wants it exactly
he wants what he wants what he wants to
and uh one of the I think one of the
funniest quirks and a number of Royals
have this the queen had it as well they
don't like Square ice cubes they carry
round ice cube trays have them brought
with them wherever they go because they
don't like the clinking sound that
square cubes make oh I can't even
isn't that great
[Music]